hi everyone our colleagues in New York
asked us to do a reporter's notebook so
on behalf of my team we were kind of
sitting here thinking where exactly do
you begin right we've been on the island
for roughly 48 hours so I thought we'd
start where it all ended for us it ends
here in uma kau we just filed our last
report for the CBS Evening News and uma
cows on the southeastern part of the
island and as I look out I'm reminded
that I want to come back here at some
point for a vacation
that's Las Palmas the orange roofs and
sort of the buildings that are farthest
in the distance from where we are the
closest to the water but I also want to
point out how green and lush things are
here might not seem like a big deal but
I remember after the hurricane
everything was brown and I mean
everything
in fact it reminded me of covering
wildfires in Southern California our
time here has been productive exhausting
at moments haven't slept much and have
an incredible team of people you may
have heard me say that there's no
television without the people behind the
scenes right so what places we went to
while we were here ooh tato salinas de
boku wa uma cow san juan cog was in fact
in congress I want to tell you it was
actually our security guard who
mentioned that there were people in the
area who were helping to direct traffic
driving around the island one thing that
I noticed six months later is that most
of the traffic lights are not working
but the people who are directing traffic
are locals they're not police officers
they're not government workers
I'm told that homeless people have
stepped in to help and regular folks who
either don't have a job or in between
jobs have put on a reflective vest grab
the whistle and are directing traffic at
intersections we spoke to a man who said
he gets paid tipped regularly by drivers
they rolled down the window we even saw
a police officer who stopped at a light
and listened to the directions of this
gentleman who was directing traffic I
mean it's sort of just an accepted way
of life here on the island and it and
sort of a sign again of what we've seen
over the last six months which is Puerto
Ricans depending more on each other than
they depend on their government a lot of
people will tell you they have been
disappointed by
actions of the government the government
will tell you it was a storm of epic
proportions right it was a it was a
storm that they anticipated but the
infrastructure on the island just could
not withstand it
speaking of infrastructure it's worth
it's it's coming to mind I don't know if
many of you are aware but the Army Corps
of Engineers that's working here on the
island working alongside prepa is
operating under the Stafford Act and the
Stafford Act actually prevents them from
doing any redesigns or upgrades to the
grid so many of you have reached out to
me on social media and said David is the
grid going to be better after the work
is done is it going to be better than
what it was before Berea and the answer
is no it's gonna be the exact same and
here's why the Stafford Act authorizes
the US Army Corps of Engineers to bring
in brigades and and workers to make
repairs where they need to be and
replacements where necessary right so if
a pole is not demolished and can be
repaired they just repair it if the pole
is you know decimated then they put a
new pole in but they're not gonna
redesign that grid in that municipality
to be better stronger or more resilient
because the Stafford Act doesn't
authorize that some other highlights for
our trip this trip was actually the
first time I got to tato the bridge has
been rebuilt and that bridge is
essential I mean you had thousands of
people in the mountains who were cut off
from civilization one lady told me she
was actually unable to get out of her
house initially after the storm in
hooter Watteau for about three weeks
couldn't even leave her home not to
mention actually get down the mountain
to try and cross the bridge I also
wanted to make a point in coming here of
not just highlighting the bad stuff
there's a whole lot of good things that
are happening happening in fact when we
rode around the island what I was struck
by is how everything seemed to be open
and people seemed to be going about
their daily life with little with little
interruption
so most people were working in fact talk
about a big change for us as we saw
interviews sought out interviews with
folks we were told by many people oh
they're at work oh they're working
they're on time for enter
yes right when we were here after the
storm everybody a time because
everybody's job was shutdown nothing was
working but we actually had some trouble
trying to get folks to talk because they
were working that's a good sign no more
lines to get money at the bank no more
lines to get gas we went to the smallest
areas actually coming from
we went Salinas Caguas down to Ponce a
and sort of between no where do we go
how do we what was that gas station I
think was outside upon say in a very
rural area at any rate in a very rural
area stopped by a gas station and they
had fueled no long lines and those small
really rural stations were the ones who
were sort of some of the last to get it
so to speak we didn't spend much time in
San Juan on this trip in fact what I did
when we when we started this trip was we
were sitting down talking about what
stories and wanted to do and I said you
know we have such a loyal audience that
has followed our reporting since the
beginning let's reach out to them and
see what we should do and there was
actually a college professor who took a
look at all of the responses and made a
list and said of the responses back to
David beg no people said go to these and
at the top of the list was uma cow the
java KOA and to otto and we got to all
of those places so i also heard from
many of you don't go to san juan things
are fine and so we didn't do much in san
juan because we wanted to make sure we
got out into the rural areas where there
are more issues right some other
highlights the governor announced
actually on the anniversary the
six-month anniversary of hurricane maria
that he was establishing a rainy day
fund and I called his spokeswoman to get
more information and essentially what
she told me was this rainy day fund is
going to be used to help bring in
brigades electrical brigades faster
right because you might remember after
the storm it took so long to get repair
crews here and it not only took time to
get crews here but it took even more
time to get the supplies that the crews
needed here right so they got the men on
the island to do the power work but they
needed the poles and it took weeks in
some cases months I mean it was
agonizing period speaking about that our
member interviewing Colonel Kirk of the
US Army Corps of Engineers who spoke
quite candidly and said you know David
my dad asked me why don't you guys put
the power poles underground that's how
we do it stateside why don't you make it
safer and more resilient in Puerto Rico
and he said I told my dad number one we
can't because we're operating out of the
Stafford Act but he said number two if
we tried to do that all around the
island we could have taken us a year or
more to restore power because it would
have taken so much time so anyway that's
kind of everything that's on the top of
my head in my heart right now I'll end
with something kind of comical at least
it is to me
so lin-manuel Miranda sent out a tweet
earlier today saying I was an honorary
Puerto Rican and by the way somebody
asked me the other day aren't you from
Puerto Rico and I said not only am I not
from Puerto Rico I had never been a
Puerto Rico and I didn't know what Porto
Rican before the hurricane but any rate
Lind sent out a tweet today saying I was
an honorary Puerto Rican and thanking
CBS for our work and he said you know
David you won't have to pay for and I
hope I pronounce this correctly past
Dallas but did I say it right past Ellis
you'll appreciate this our fixer who is
a local from the island when I said it
the wrong way he kind of grimaced but at
any rate I had to respond I said I don't
even know what that is but what I do
know is that a slice of my heart will
always remain in Puerto Rico we are
grateful to the people of Puerto Rico
the Americans who live here for allowing
us to tell their story and we will
continue to tell those stories online on
broadcast and on social media I am I am
hell-bent on not letting people forget
about what's happening here in Puerto
Rico so thanks for listening I hope it
was worth your time and I'll see you on
social media and on TV of course